bonsoir il est 18h nouvelle édition du
78 lactu sur TVfil 78 le journal de la
rédaction et ce 11 mars dans l'actualité
la mobilisation des sagesfemmes qui va
se poursuivre notamment à l'hôpital
André Mignot au chînet 76 % d'entre
elles souhaitent la poursuite d'un
mouvement social national débuté en
octobre dernier les annonces de la
ministre la semaine dernière sur leur
futur statut ne les ont pas rassuré
Marie soltouren annonçait notamment la
création d'un statut médical de la
sage-femme des hôpitaux elle répondent
que les avancées proposées n'en sont
finalement pas que certains points de
promesse ont déjà été faits par le passé
sans réel résultats vient communiquer le
collectif des sages-femmes fait savoir
qu'elles sont plus déterminées que
jamais et prête à en découdre animateur
radio été les comédiens maintenant
réalisateur Manu paayet présenté en ce
début de semaine à l'UGC de 50 cont on
Yveline situation amoureuse c'est
compliqué une comédie romantique très
personnelle j'ai trouvé ça très drôle
très amusant et je le conseille à tout
le monde très bonne comédie très bon
aller voir vraiment aller voir d'urgence
très
sympa pas croir ce que je vais te dire
qui est entré dans mon bureau pas plus
tard que hier Vanessa best
une Vanessa bestel avec S mich un
million de dollars la plus belle
gonzesse qu'on est connu toi et moi oh
la oh il y a du monde ou quoi là un
mariage pas forcément bien engagé un
amour d'enfance qui ressurgit un
trentenaire en plein dilemme le point de
départ du premier film en tant que
réalisateur et scénariste de Manu paayet
je ne connais pas de film français qui
est déjà évoqué cette fille cette star
du collège ou du lycée la fille dont
tout le monde était jaloux ou tout le
monde était
amoureux et qui est resté un peu dans
nos têtes à nous euh voilà moi je me
souviens encore de son évidemment de son
prénom et de son nom et à chaque fois
que je pose la question à un copain il
me sort Caro Berti quand je me suis
rendu compte que ça concernait un peu
plus de gens que que moi voilà je me
suis dit ok il faut qu'on en fasse un
film il faut qu'on en fasse une comédie
romantique une comédie romantique très
apprécié du public de l'UGC Skywest et
auré hâte du dernier Grand Prix du
Festival du Film de Comédie de l'Alpe de
e au côté de Manu paayet pour présenter
le film ce soir là son coréalisateur
rodolp Loga et sa future épouse à
l'écran la Coméd anï de Moustier et un
ami pour le moins envahissant dans ce
film Jean-François carré j'aime beaucoup
ce film parce qu'il me ressemble
beaucoup parce qui me fait encore rire
alors que je l'ai vu vous imaginez un
grand nombre de fois mais que on y a
mis plein de répliqu qu'on adore avec
Romain et plein
d'acteurs qui nous qui nous font rire et
qui nous
émeuvent à l'intérieur y a pas de signe
tu es avec Juliette c'est elle ta meuf
vous êtes complémentaire à fond la
mousse là je vois tes
couilles mesdames et messieurs arrivé de
la plus belle fille de la soirée en même
temps c'est la seule
valessaa faut absolument que tu la
baises bah julietteen à de
Juliette situation amoureuse c'est
compliqué ffiche le 19 mars une sortie
délicate alors que sont annoncés
plusieurs comédies et que reste toujours
à laffiche les Inconnus encore Danny
boun pour le comédien Sam Carman
installé dans le département le choix
est en tout cas déjà fait il y a de la
vanne c'est drôle c'est tomber par terre
de drôlerie mais en plus il y a du cœur
et c'est bien joué quoi je sais que les
places sont chères tous les mercredis là
il y a plusieurs films français mais
celui-làoup de comédie oui en ce moment
donc Fall ouais il y a pas que des
bonnes celle-là c'est une bonne l'invité
à présent de ce journal c'est Isabelle
pandazopouos bonsoir vous êtes auteur
vous êtes aussi professeur de lettres
vous avez enseigné dans des zones
difficiles vous prenez aujourd'hui en
charge des élèves en situation de handic
handicap pardon psychique si vous êtes
avec nous aujourd'hui c'est pour la
présentation d'un ouvrage la décision
dont on va voir la couverture dans un
inst instant sorti en janvier 2013 chez
galimar jeesse il est aujourd'hui édité
étudié voilà par des élèves de 50 ans en
yeline vous venez à leur rencontre on va
parler de ces différents échanges mais
d'abord sur l'ouvrage en lui-même le le
choix le pitch un petit peu Louise élève
de terminal S très bon élève un matin
elle se sent mal finalement elle se
retrouve seule et elle accouche d'un
enfant dont elle ne savait rien c'est un
dénis de grossesse plus même puisqu'elle
dit n'avoir aucune relation sexuelle il
y a assez peu d'ouvrages qui traitent de
cette problématique de roman sur ce
sujet le dénis de grossesse concernerait
environ 1600 femmes par an 350 d'entre
elles découvriraient même justement leur
situation de grossesse au moment
d'accoucher comme l'héroïne de votre
roman qu'est-ce qui vous a poussé à
écrire autour de cette thématique le
fait que ce soit assez rare dans la
littérature justement aussi oui
effectivement et et surtout que on en
fait c'est traité par les médias de
façon
spectaculaire sans jamais d'analyse euh
c'est-à-dire que on en parle au moment
où quand les femmes du coup bascule dans
l'infanticide et du coup ça
m'intéressait d'essayer de comprendre
pourquoi ce phénomène là parce que
moi-même j'y comprenais rien que c'était
extrêmement mystérieux et du coup j'ai
beaucoup lu je me suis beaucoup
documenté et j'ai eu envie de
transmettre cette compréhension là
comment vous avez travaillé justement
vous dites vous vous êtes beaucoup
documenté vous avez rencontré des femmes
dans ce dans ce type de situation des
jeunes femmes j'ai euh
je j'ai beaucoup lu des notamment il y a
une psychanalyste en France qui est
spécialiste de la question euh et qui a
ouvert une consultation à Nant et donc
elle qui s'appelle sophie Marinopoulos
et euh sinon pour j'ai j'ai rencontré
des jeunes femmes mèr adolescentes dans
une dans un centre maternel au montboron
à Nice où la directrice m'a ouvert les
portes et où j'ai pu pendant 2 jours
observer la vie de cet endroit c'est un
livre difficile aussi peut-être parce
que vous parlez non seulement du dénis
grossesse mais aussi de la question du
viol de la question de l'adoption aussi
ce sont des problématiques très sérieuse
très très grave vous avez choisi de de
le traiter de quelle manière justement
vous vouliez lever les les mystères qui
entourer justement toutes les
complications que rencontrent aussi ces
femmes lorsqu'il faut choisir est-ce
qu'on laisse son enfant être adopté par
exemple aussi euh la problématique de
l'abandon en fait c'est un c'est un
sujet complètement tabou en France
euh personne ne connaît ou n'a entendu
parler ça n'existe pas dans la
littérature et il existe des livres
d'enfants adoptés
qui tracent leur parcours et qui peuvent
écrire ou se positionner ou réfléchir
autour de leur
compréhension ou de leur désir de
comprendre ce qui leur est arrivé autant
les femmes qui confi leur enfant à
l'adoption et qui ne décid de ne pas
être mère on n'en parle pas et du coup
ça m'intéressait d'essayer là encore
d'essayer de comprendre c'est quoi ce
mécanisme et comment on peut le penser
autrement parce qu'effectivement de ce
que j'en ai lu aussi ça ne se passe pas
du tout dans de la même manière dans les
autres sociétés sur d'autres continents
là vous échangez actuellement avec des
collégiens avec des lycéens des lycéenes
des collégiennes également quelles sont
les les thématiques qui les qui les
absorbent le plus sur lesquelles ils ont
envie de réagir de de parler avec vous
d'échanger euh alors c'est très riche et
c'est très ouvert donc ils sont beaucoup
dans des questionnements qui sont les
vôtres et puis beaucoup sur qui sont des
questions littéraires il y a beaucoup de
questions littéraires sur les techniques
narratives sur plusur aussi voilài mais
parce qu'en fait le le le livre laisse
ouvert et complexe le champ de de de de
de l'interprétation et du coup ils
viennent me demander et on peut débattre
ensemble des questions qui sont posées
au lecteurs vous êtes en effet à
saint-quenttin à l'invitation du centre
de ressources pour les professionnels de
l'enfance qui fait partie du réseau des
médiiathèques hier l'échange a eu lieu
avec des lycéens de la plaine de nfle à
trrape je vous propose justement
d'écouter quelquesuns de de ces jeunes
avant de poursuivre la discussion cette
rencontre elle été bien parce queelle
nous a apporté ben plein de réponses à
nos questions par exemple pourquoi elle
a choisi ce thème pourquoi elle a fait
le basculement entre son premier livre
et son deuxième
livre aussi son salaire on a pu savoir
ce qu'elle ressentait sur le livre et
tout ça et comment elle l'a écrit dans
quelles conditions à quoi elle a pensé
quand elle l'a écrit je trouve ça très
bien la façon dont elle à la fait nous a
dit comment elle elle fonctionnait pour
écrire un livre et
que que c'était pas forcément facile on
se dit pas voilà je vais écrire un livre
je vais sortir une feuille un stylo et
voilà j'écris un livre c'est c'est
beaucoup de travail voilà pour ces
différentes réactions et puis je précise
aussi que le reportage complet sur votre
intervention dans cet établissement sera
découvrir lors du magazine kiosque avec
Aelia de BC ce sera demain mercredi à
18h30 on les a entendu hein il
s'intéresse aussi al pas seulement à
votre salaire mais sur la façon don dont
vous écrivez c'est aussi là le but de
votre démarche le leur ouvir possit
c'est très touchant parce qu'en fait je
pense que ça ça concerne aussi bien les
les ados que les adultes il y a toujours
cette question de l'inspiration de de
c'est quoi ce moment de création et
pourquoi puisqueen fait c'est pas pour
l'argent euh et du coup j'essaie de
répondre et en même temps ça reste
mystérieux pour moi et et j'essaie de
démystifier un petit peu l'acte
d'écriture comme une inspiration qui me
tomberait dessus parce que je serais élu
euh c'est un travail le travail de
création c'est d'abord un travail et euh
avec des moments où bah j'élimine des
pages je transforme un personnage je
change de chemin en cours de route je me
pose plein de questions voilà et c'est
ça le plaisir il y a des questions qui
vous interpellent parfois qui vous
surprennent que oui il y a une très
belle question cet après-midi à voisin
avec un professeur qui avait
remarquablement préparé ses élèves qui
était euh comment est-ce que ce livre là
aurait été reçu il y a 50 ans et je
pense qu'effectivement il n'aurait pas
été publié dans une édition jeunesse
c'était impossible d'abord ça n'existait
pas vraiment et puis en plus je pense
qu'il y a 50 ans il aurait fait
prodigieusement
scandale et justement ça a été difficile
de de rentrer dans les écoles pour
aborder ce sujet euh pas du tout
absolument pas en fait le le les les les
les documentalistes le CRPF un travail
et Armel Hervé particulièrement que je
remercie fait un travail remarquable
et de autant je pense que les personnes
qui n'ont pas lu le livre peuvent être
extrêmement surprises des thèmes comme
vous les avez cités comme ça on peut
dire mais c'est quoi cette histoire
autant ceux qui rentre dans le livre je
pense que du coup sont avec les
personnages et sont dans le
questionnement réel euh et du coup je
pense que c'est pour enfin de ça je suis
très contente merci d'être venu nous
parler donc de cet ouvrage de ces
échanges le livre La décision édition et
galimar jeunesse les échanges qui se
poursuivent avec ses élèves de cqu1 en
Yveline ce sera notamment jeudi au lycée
des SEM RAM morpa et l'encours voilà une
toute dernière question est-ce que vous
avez lu le concours 2013 de Pierre Le
maîre non mais j'ai très envie et bah
justement alors il est à 550S en Eveline
lui aussi il y a quelques jours pour la
transition à montinî bretonne au pavé du
canal il s'est prêté au jeu des
dédicaces alors que revoir là-haut
l'œuvre qui lui a value cette
distinction en 2013 va bientôt toucher
un nouveau public en étant adapté en
bande dessinée Sabrina sini et et
lodimine il est venu leur raconter une
histoire l'histoire du livre qui lui a
permis d'atteindre la consécration loin
des projecteurs tier le maître est
revenu sur les origines d' revoir
là-haut primé l'année dernière par
l'Académie goncour l'occasion pour
l'écrivain passionné par la Première
Guerre mondiale de rencontrer des
lecteurs dont il se sent parfois éloigné
vous savez le travail d'un d'un
romancier c'est un travail assez
solitaire et le moment de la parution
d'un livre c'est la seule asion de
l'année que vous avez de de rencontrer
les gens au fond pour qui vous écrivez
lors de cette rencontre Pierre le Mare a
séduit son public en alliant confidence
et trèsumour je vous jure j'ai écrit des
romans il se passe des trucs totalement
vraisemblable mais globalement ça marche
et moi ce qui m'importe c'est
l'émotion moi mon
boulot mon travail mon job en racontant
des histoires c'est provoquer des
émotions je je vous donne la parole
monsieur merci de poser une question
c'est très
aimablez à mon secours une opération
intéressante pour la librairie qui a
misé sur la notoriété du romancier pour
attirer les lecteurs pierre le maître
avait écrit des polares avant de
d'écrire son proncour et ça faisait
longtemps que j'avais envie de le voir
et de de faire une rencontre avec lui je
pense que
c'est c'est convivial amical d'avoir une
relation comme ça avec un auteur je
trouve ça formidable je trouve ça déjà
c'est bien d'avoir de mettre un visage à
à un nom quoi enfin sur un bouquin donc
non c'est c'est vraiment très
extraordinaire en plus c'est quelqu'un
de très très agréable en qui qui sait
communiquer ses émotions ça me fait
mieux comprendre encore le livre et ça
me donne envie de lire tout ce qu'il
écrit on lit le livre un petit peu comme
un policier on se demande jusqu'où il va
aller et en plus c'est très très bien
écrit c'est tellement agréable une belle
écriture cette adhésion du public pouss
pierre le matre à adapter son uvre en
bande dessinée une nouvelle aventure qui
le reconduira peut-être du côté de
Saint-Quentin en
Yveline lecture vient demain à 18h sur
TVfil n'oubliez pas ce soir une nouvelle
édition de municipal 2014 le magazine
pour faire le tour de l'actualité
politique à moins de 15 jours du premier
tour du scrutin excellente soirée sur
notre
antenne